in the African rainforests of Congo
National Geographic biologist Mike Fay
runs into a three-ton surprise the
elephant seems more curious than alarmed
until it starts to lumber towards
Michael it flares its years and trumpets
a warning if it charges Mike he could
easily be crushed so what's the best way
to avoid its lethal assault should he
run between its legs turn and run away
or scream and yell according to Mike Fay
the correct answer is C scream and yell
once you're engaged you do not show your
back to that elephant you do not turn
you do not run because if you do he will
chase you they're very fast they're
stealth and he can easily if he really
wants to he can catch up deep and you
just don't want to run away
the probability of getting killed is
much lower if you stand your ground than
if you run yell louder and louder and
louder I don't know who's more nervous
me or her